ble C podcast man J Stone in the
building new albums dropping the
definition of success November 22nd yeah
go watch our interview we about to have
him do what he does man let's get right
to it shout out to Mazy Man play some of
that Mazy come on man Press
Play Let's Go this what we on yes sir
shout out the homie Mazy come on man
shout out Mazy let's get
it check me out look if [__] know me
the [__] know if [__] know steeve
the [__] know if [__] know me [__]
know if [__] know stev and [__] know
look from fifth SLO in the sacks OFF
Fifth my whole team bosses you can still
get nip slap my business is intact with
more options she be watching all my
stories like soap operas used to be the
show stopper now when I drop on top 10
and more than four genres without good
weed I can't Co proper gold bbs's gold
necklace with the bbs's c smoking in the
Gs Lexus out in Texas with BN be I'm
From The Trenches with the Drillers like
we do construction abundantly hoes
funding me the D boys front of me I
couldn't live comfortably the D's might
come for me [__] was stunning on me
then I got money I'm laughing to the
bank that thought it was funny when I
was hungry reaching Heights that can't
measure up level up beel up oy a pet go
another level
up shopping in New York got me fresh as
[__] shopping on Rodeo got me fresh as
[__] I quit believing in luck got my
blessings up [__] bank they sinko Ultra
I'm so solo to she put lip stick on my
poloo YOLO he only live his life once so
go hard in the paint you can't miss your
chance to blow just in case you forgot I
got songs with E40 and two of the lot
[__] Styles and J the kiss W and tip I
got songs with Snoop I got songs with NI
I got beat with did a track with OT and
we put that on
[__] what mixtap with DJ Drama juicing J
and do on it sty currency and cash doll
on it [__] hey hey look man new mixtape
new album coming out November 22nd man
the definition of success J Stone you
already know let's get it boom West hey
appreciate you guys watching this
freestyle we got another one coming and
then another one and then another one
and they're all brought to you by our
good Folks at LRG clothing you already
know what it is LRG been keeping you fly
for years they got so much new fly gear
right now
l-r-g.com promo code bootleg when you
check out you'll save 30% off l
l-r-g.com another freestyles on the way
presented by LRG